in the opening scene two friends arrive
on a mysterious looking Island hoping to
find a lost treasure there is nothing
but water on all sides and not even a
single organism lives there the friends
slowly make their way to the island when
suddenly it starts moving to their
horror the island turns out to be a
large Blue Whale which has been chained
by someone or something following this
the movie cuts to some weeks in the past
at midnight a majestic white mare dashes
across a vast Wheat Field creating a
trail of luminous light behind it the
next morning an old farmer summons his
three sons to display the story site of
their ravaged Wheat Field since their
only source of income is getting
destroyed the man orders his sons to
keep watch at night hoping to catch the
culprit behind it the brothers then
delegate this responsibility to the
youngest one named John John is scared
of the dark and he knows that the task
at hand is immense but to gain his
father's trust he agrees to keep watch
in the evening Jon strikes up a friendly
conversation with the Hedgehog he had
rescued earlier as he chats he notices
the silhouette of the mare and quickly
throws a rope in its direction suddenly
the Rope tightens and the mare begins to
drag Jon through the fields in Meadows
at one point he is even dragged through
the skies from where he can see the
beautiful Village Jon is mesmerized by
The View and he begins shouting with joy
but his happy time soon comes to an end
when the mayor crashes and they both end
up in a bog Jon manages to get himself
out but the mayor remains stuck seeing
the poor animal drowning Jon forgets his
mission and instead tries to help it he
tries pulling the giant mare out by
himself but the Beast doesn't even budge
so he Powers up a nearby wheat Mill and
eventually rescues it the mayor
overwhelmed with gratitude sheds a tear
which touches John deeply he then
releases the mare from its bindings
making it promise that it will no longer
trample their fields after the mayor
departs Jon looks upon the desolate
wheat field and realizes that he will
have to bear the consequences of the
destruction the next day the morning
after the incident John wakes up in the
stable where he is amazed to find two
magnificent black Royal horses as he
takes in the sight of these creatures he
suddenly hears a voice in the background
which startles him reacting quickly he
grabs a pitchfork and attempts to defend
himself but when he approaches the
source of the noise Jon is surprised to
find a small humpbacked magic foal he
can miraculously speak just like a human
full informs Jon that the mare he
encountered earlier is his mother and
she has gifted these two horses to him
with full himself coming along to
support Jon not long after the old
farmer screams out in despair upon
seeing the state of the destroyed Wheat
Field causing Jon to panic sensing the
problematic situation full acts swiftly
carrying Jon on his back as they race
away from the field with great speed
along the way Jon expresses his desire
to sell the horses to acquire some much
needed funds bull once again agrees to
help and lets at a piercing whistle
summoning the horses to their location
before Jon's family could capture them
now with the Majestic horses in toe the
group sets off on a journey to the
bustling Market Town hoping to find a
suitable buyer upon arriving there John
is bombarded with offers from eager
buyers vying for the chance to own the
Regal horses however because of greed he
chooses to retain the animals and sell
them only to the richest person in the
area that person is revealed to be none
other than the king as John walks near
the Grand Palace the king spots the
horses and becomes mesmerized however
instead of buying them like a gentleman
he orders his men to capture them saying
a poor farmer like John could have never
bought the horses by himself feeling
dejected and without any funds Jon turns
to full for help the latter once again
lets out a whistle summoning the horses
back to John's side but in the process
the animals knocked the king over into a
nearby bag of flour despite the king's
anger he keeps his composure in front of
the gathered public John then proposes a
trade requesting two silver hats in
exchange for the horses however one of
the king's courtiers reminds him that
the horses are bound to keep running
back to Jon taking this into account the
king offers him the prestigious role of
the most important groom in the palace
John is over the moon to have received
such an opportunity so he accepts
without thinking twice and because of
the announcement the entire crowd also
starts cheering for him they believe
that he is the animal Whisperer as John
gains more and more popularity among the
people the king becomes increasingly
jealous of him and seeks to find a way
to execute him however he cannot find a
valid reason to do so but one day his
courtier gives him an idea according to
his plan he has to send Jon on a mission
to capture the legendary Firebird since
it is an impossible task Jon will surely
fail and this can be used as a reason to
execute him hearing this the king starts
laughing maniacally and sends the order
elsewhere when Jon learns about the
mission he becomes determined to
complete it full warns him that the
firebird has never been tamed by anyone
and this might prove to be an
impractical task but Jon is determined
to impress the villagers so the two
eventually set out on their Journey
along the way they Venture into the
forest to collect some dream nuts to
lure the firebird Jon is curious and
wants to try the nuts but I want to lick
the dream nuts but full forbids him from
eating them warning him that they act as
a sedative following this they walk all
day and finally reach an oasis in the
desert which is the Abode of the
firebird there they see a warning about
the presence of liquid sand regardless
Jon throws the dream nuts and hides
nearby after a while the Majestic bird
emerges from the ground and begins
munching on those knots according to the
plan the nuts begin to intoxicate the
bird but before falling asleep it
notices the chill and starts to attack
Jon and full are almost killed on many
occasions but they always come to the
rescue of one another the entire
landscape is also demolished because of
the ensuing Chase but in the end the
nuts finally knock out the firebird
allowing Jon to capture it with chains
the next day John and full find the
firebird looking weak and shedding a
fiery tear foal explains that the bird
can only be hot when it is free if it
remains on the ground for a long time it
loses all its energy hearing this Jon
feels pity for the bird so he decides to
free it as soon as he takes the chains
off the Beast regains its fire and flies
away into the skies but not before
leaving a fire feather for John now that
the mission has failed fool suggests
that they'd not return to the kingdom as
it may result in Jon's execution however
our brave but stubborn protagonist is
sure the fire feather will prove that
they caught the firebird upon their
return the king orders their execution
as expected Jon tries to prove himself
explaining that he caught the bird but
then set it free out of compassion
however the king refuses to believe his
story and an execution raises an ax to
deliver the final blow but right then
the Majestic Firebird appears casting a
bright light over the kingdom it heard
John's pleas for help and has now
arrived to return the favor the people
are baffled when they notice the
firebird following Jon's orders hence
the king reluctantly allows Jon to live
and also throws a feast in his honor
that night John is celebrated as a hero
in the Kingdom as the king's frustration
grows he is instigated by his curtier to
send Jon on an impossible task to
retrieve the king Maiden who resides in
an ice kingdom Atop A High Rock the king
is convinced that Jon will fail and
thereby he will have a reason to execute
him so the very next day a messenger
announces the King's new assignment to
John who accepts the challenge without
any hesitation after scaling the
treacherous High Rock mountains John and
full finally arrive at the entrance of
the palace where the king Maiden resides
however they find that the palace is
blocked by a massive wall of ice making
it impossible to enter but with the help
of the feather gifted by the firebird
Jon is able to melt down the ice barrier
causing a ton of water to gush out
unfortunately this freezes full in a
ball of ice sending him tumbling down
the cliff The Landing is a bad one but
he manages to survive without any
injuries meanwhile Jon enters the palace
where he comes across the empress he
introduces himself to be a Matchmaker
sent by the king but the empress tells
him that she has no interest in marrying
as there are no Heroes left to test his
bravery she jumps off a cliff and Jon
immediately follows suit to rescue her
impressed by his Courage the empress
deploys her gown as a parachute and
starts descending slowly but just then
Jon accidentally punctures the Gown
causing both of them to Tumble at great
speed it appears as if they are going to
die a painful death but full shows up
with a pair of new wings and rescues
both of them later that night the three
camp in the middle of the forest before
continuing their Journey Back To The
Kingdom during this time full advises
Jon to abandon the empress and and flee
to save himself but he refuses the
empress who has been eavesdropping on
their conversation is flustered by Jon's
loyalty the next morning the trio
arrived at the Kingdom where John is
greeted with a hero's welcome everyone
is surprised to see that Jon has
returned from his mission alive which
only fuels the king's growing resentment
towards him despite this the king is
compelled to reward him one more time
later that night John confides and fall
about his feelings for the empress and
decides to visit her he takes some
flowers and climbs up to her window but
their reunion is cut short when some
courtiers enter with clothes for her to
wear after a while the empress finally
meets the king and gets displeased to
learn that he's the age of her father
outside John becomes jealous upon seeing
the two together the king wants to marry
the empress the very next day but she is
reluctant in order to delay it she
mentions that it is her family heritage
to get married with a special ring but
sadly the ring was lost in the ocean
hearing this the king becomes enraged
and so he sends John on yet another
impossible task that same night as full
Ponders Jon's erratic Behavior he sees
the spirit of a whale soaring through
the sky full speaks with the sun moon
and wind and learns that the ring is
inside the belly of a giant whale which
has now turned into an island in the
early hours of the day John and foe set
off on a journey to the whale fish only
to find her Bound by chains fole manages
to communicate with the whale and learns
that she was put in the state by some
Sailors as a punishment her crime she
devoured several ships for fun at that
time she was young and naive but now she
regrets her actions soon after the whale
sheds a tear which gives Jon an idea to
make her sneeze and break free from the
chains so they ride into the whale's
nostrils and tickle its interior with
the tip of foal's feathers the plan
works and the large mammal starts
struggling to itch itself in the process
it breaks free of all its chains and
also releases the trapped ships after
decades the whale then rewards Jon and
full the precious ring as a gesture of
thanks in the next scene the two make
their way back to the empress's window
to deliver the ring however their
presence does not go unnoticed as guards
and a courtiers spot them through a
scope and rush to capture Jon the
commotion wakes the king who grabs his
gun and rushes to the window seeing full
the king shoots him without hesitation
on the other hand the guards Storm Into
the bedchamber and to rest Jon falsely
accusing him of kidnapping the king
Maiden after this the king gets ready to
marry the empress but in order to buy
more time she demands that he rejuvenate
himself through a recipe passed down
from her grandmother she requires him to
bathe in three cauldrons one filled with
boiling water the second with ice water
and the third with boiling milk the plan
is a clever one but it results in even
deeper problems for Jon sensing that it
may be a trap a courtier advises the
king to test the cauldrons on Jon before
subjecting himself to the process at
night the empress secretly confides in
full that she knows how to nullify the
effect of the boiling contents she
reveals that throwing her grandmother's
ring in the first cauldron a feather
from the firebird into the second and
the flower of life and death that grows
at the end of the world in the third
cauldron will cancel out the deadly
effects wait a sec that third one sounds
kind of hard to find she claims that
Jon's survival hinges on their success
in executing this plan full who was
injured by The Gunshot earlier knows
that it is a treacherous mission that
may result in his demise but for the
sake of his best friend he sets out to
find the flower since he cannot fly
anymore he uses his lightning speed to
travel to the end of the world full
eventually finds the flower but it warns
him that whosoever plucks it will be
awaiting dead despite the ominous
warning full plucks the flower to save
Jon in the morning the king
hypocritically declares that he is
giving Jon a chance at Redemption and
orders him to jump into the cauldrons
the latter believes that he is about to
die so he bravely professes his love for
the empress he then jumps into the
boiling water and at the same time the
empress successfully throws the ring
into the first cauldron helping Jon
emerge unharmed in the second cauldron
the firebird drops a feather keeping Jon
safe once again meanwhile full manages
to deliver the flower just in time for
Jon to be saved in the third and final
cauldron after successfully completing
his Rejuvenation John appears before the
empress who is amazed at his
transformation the king is also shocked
and believes that the recipe actually
makes people younger so he jumps into
the first cauldron but as soon as he
does so a huge bubble emerges and
Carries him away inside of it the people
of the Kingdom only laugh at his
Misfortune and instead start chanting
for Jon the king is an throw him
in the milk meanwhile the empress and
Jon notice that full is missing so they
start searching for him they soon find
him sitting patiently and waiting for
his death as he had plucked the flower
however the empress reveals that the
flowers warning was simply a task to
assess The Bravery of the person who
picked it she could have told him that
before he left she also clears that if
foe had not plucked it he would act
actually have died but now he won't
hearing this fold delightfully gets up
and hugs his best friend in the final
scene the crowd cheers for Jon demanding
that he become the new king he happily
accepts and vows to protect the kingdom
with all his might the movie ends as Jon
and the empress finally get married and
take over the kingdom as the newly
crowned king and queen subscribe for
more videos like this turn on
notifications and leave a like to help
the channel out thank you for watching